[Music]
what I do to make our goats know this is
a recipe that a couple shared with me
that it has goats already and they said
this is a little bit more gentle on
their stomach than the powdered mix at
the like flea farm or like country
stores and stuff like that this won't
cause them to have an upset stomach or
get sick from it I know there's a bunch
of different mixes out there that you
can use for baby goats and the goats
that we have were nursed until we got
them so when we got them they're only
two weeks old and then I had to fight
off you then so I'm gonna show you
exactly what I do and the recipe that
was shared to me to use for them and so
far it's been I think like six days so
far on here and so far they've been
doing really good you guys can kind of
see in the video they do really well
with it so I'm gonna share with you what
I do for that so what we use is whole
milk buttermilk and then evaporated milk
so what I was told to do is pour out as
much milk as maybe like maybe four cups
or so just so I have enough room in my
gallon of milk to add the things that I
need to add so the only thing that I
really need to measure out it is the
better buttermilk and that is just a cup
[Music]
okay so a cup of buttermilk goes right
in the gallon a whole can of you've ever
that's not gonna go over very well
okay so much easier if you use a funnel
because then I can just dump it right in
there
still then I add that and there's only
just like enough in there that and then
I just pour what I can for the rest of
the milk in there to make it a full
gallon then you just shake it up so I'm
gonna go ahead right away and make them
some bottles because they need to feed
right now but I want to share with you
how I made that the rest of the milk I
just dumped in the other gallon that we
have in the fridge so then I write on
here that it is goat milk so nobody
accidentally grabs the Hat
and what I do for feeding them and the
measurement I used for that is I take
one of our just like a mason jar but
this is like a smaller smaller jar I
fill it up all the way to the top so I
go all the way then I put it in the
microwave for a minute and thirty
seconds
I'll go put this stuff away while that's
in there and then I will show you what
bottles I'm using okay so the bottles
that we're using are just regular soda
bottles I have them labeled in their
name and then these we got from the
tractor supply place in area bio so that
fits on there this is what we were told
to use from the couple that helped me
with deciding what milk to use and then
with one of our goats the little one he
is having a problem with drinking down
to this one so I went and got a baby
bottle that has like a slow flow to it
and he does much better on this one so I
still want to keep this around just in
case he gets a little bit better but
they only are on a bottle for a period
of time and then eventually we will wean
them off and they won't be using it
anyway so but right now this is what I'm
using and I will show you the
that each of them get okay so I for
opals I fill it all the way up to like
there's kind of like a line right here
so I kind of fill it up to there or
almost there and I already have it
measured out that she's getting 8 ounces
so that's a holes bottle
and with Winchester's I only need just a
little bit so he only drinks like like
an ounce or two maybe he's not he's the
the Nigerian Dwarf one so he doesn't
drink as much
so he won't even drink all of that but
that's that's how I make their bottles
so they do get warm more models and we
will go to go feed them right now and
you'll see how good they're doing today
and today is Friday so now they will
need three weeks old and they're doing
much better on their bottle so we'll go
out and do that okay oppa usually does
really good and we got a new bottle for
Winchester because other one comes out
too fast so you can tell that he does
much better with this one before he was
kind of choking on the other one and
opal right here does really good I can't
really show you very go there yeah so
opal pretty much like Downton's hers
like really quick and winchester doesn't
usually drink all of his so he only gets
like one or two ounces because that's
all he pretty much does and she gets
like eight ounces and she drinks all of
hers so so tomorrow will be a week with
these guys and you guys can tell from
the beginning of the video on how we had
to kind of force-feed Winchester the
battle and now he knows exactly what to
do but we kind of had to I kind of kept
up with like a schedule
for them so I kind of kept up with a
schedule for them so that when we open
the door to their little crate thing
that they get a bottle and then then
it's playtime so this is their afternoon
feeding and then they'll get tumor
feedings today yet and they get some hay
some water and then one they're outside
they get to graze on the grass and stuff
like that and now that it's nicer out
they get to get out more often and then
eventually we'll have them just in like
a little barn or a little shed things
for them so right now we want to keep
them close so we can bottle feed them
oboes almost done
but your back okay you guys think I need
to be not your cage with Chester yeah
there you chip yep yep yep
[Music]
yeah don't quit in there
usually if I'm not videotaping I'm able
to feed both of them at the same time
oppa always does really good you're
leaving
where are you leaving on your car do you
wanna you want to feed Winchester kid
bottles right here yeah feed them
that's cuz he likes that
[Music]
we've loved all my daughter's we cuddle
he's gonna have a snacker I think it's a
little bad takes a breather need to have
a little bit more
[Music]